♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
ABOUT 20 MINUTES INTO THE 2016
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN IT WAS
PRETTY CLEAR THE AMERICAN MEDIA
WERE HORRIBLY ADDICTED TO
DONALD TRUMP.
THEY HATED TRAP, OBVIOUSLY BUT
THEY ALSO NEEDED HIM IN ORDER TO
LIVE AND THAT IS THE FACE OF
ADDICTION.
IF YOU'VE EVER SEEN A PERSON WHO
GRIMACED WHILE GULPING WARM
VODKA BEFORE BREAKFAST WITH
SHAKY HANDS YOU KNOW WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE.
THERE WAS NEVER ANY QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN
FOR SURE WHEN NEWS ORGANIZATIONS
WERE FINALLY CUT OFF FROM THEIR
VITAL DAILY SUPPLY OF
DONALD TRUMP.
THEY WERE GOING TO COLLAPSE IN A
PILE ANALYTICS EXACTLY WHAT THEY
HAVE DONE, THEY HAVE COLLAPSED.
ON TUESDAY, NOT A SINGLE SHOW ON
CNN, ONCE MOST IMPORTANT CABLE
NEWS CHANNEL IN THE WORLD --
THIS IS CNN.
NOT A SINGLE SHOW ON THE WHOLE D
800,000 VIEWERS.
THAT IS REALLY LOW.
CHRIS, WOULD BE BETTER OFF DOING
FREE CONCERTS IN THE PARK WHICH
IN FACT HE MAY BE DOING.
WITH A TRUMPET GONE, THE OLD
FORMULA NO LONGER WORKS.
THAT IS EASY TO UNDERSTAND.
WHAT IS MORE CONFUSING, HARDER
TO UNDERSTAND IS HOW THEY HAVE
RESPONDED TO THIS.
LET'S SAY YOU'VE MADE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OVER THE YEARS
SELLING RICE CRISPY TREATS TO A
HUNGRY PUBLIC.
DENTISTS MAY HAVE COMPLAINED
ABOUT WHAT YOU WERE DOING BUT
FOR YOU IT WAS ALWAYS A GREAT
BUSINESS AND YOU ASSUMED IT
WOULD GO ON FOREVER BECAUSE WE
ALWAYS THINK EVERYTHING GOOD
WILL GO ON FOREVER BUT IT
DOESN'T.
OVER TIME CONSUMERS STARTED TO
FIGURE OUT THAT A MARSHMALLOW
COATED WITH BREAKFAST CEREAL,
NOT A HEALTHY FOOD OPTION.
CASE GREAT AT FIRST COME EAT
ENOUGH AND IT STARTS TO MAKE YOU
FEEL SICK.
SO THEY BEGAN TO BUY LESS OF
WHAT YOU WERE SELLING.
FOLLOWING THIS?
HOW WOULD YOU REACT TO THAT?
IF YOU WERE SMART YOU WOULD JUST
REBRAND.
HE WOULD CHANGE THE COLOR, THROW
IN SOME VITAMIN ADDITIVES,
RENAME THE PRODUCT, YOU MAY
COLLECT CRUNCHY KALE TREATS OR
HEALTHY LIFE NUTRITION BARS.
IF YOU FIGURED OUT THAT PEOPLE
DON'T WANT SUGARY GARBAGE, THEY
WANT SOMETHING THAT IS GOOD FOR
THEM SO YOU WOULD SELL IT TO
THEM.
THAT SEEMS LIKE A RATIONAL
CHOICE.
WHAT YOU PROBABLY WOULDN'T DO IF
YOU WERE SELLING RICE CRISPY
TREATS TO A RAPIDLY SHRINKING
MARKET IS CONVINCE YOURSELF YOU
ARE NOT ON THE SNACK FOOD
BUSINESS BUT ON A MISSION
FROM GOD.
HE WOULD NOT CLAIM THAT EATING
MARSHMALLOWS IS A VITAL MORAL
IMPERATIVE.
YOU WOULD NOT ATTACK YOUR OWN
CONSUMERS FOR PREFERRING
SOMETHING ELSE.
YOU WOULD NOT DENOUNCE THEM AS
OR RACISTS FOR EATING LESS
SUGAR.
YOU WOULDN'T TRY TO BAND THE
ATKINS DIET, THAT WOULD BE
INSANE.
HE WOULD GO BANKRUPT IF YOU DID
THAT.
AND YET THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THE
LEGACY MEDIA HAVE EXCITED TO DO
AS THEY FACE EXTINCTION.
THEY HAVE AMPED UP THE MORAL
OUTRAGE, TERMS OF THE
SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS ALL THE WAY
UP TO 11, AND ABOVE ALL, THEY'VE
PRETENDED THAT NOTHING HAS
CHANGED AND THAT DONALD J. TRUMP
STILL STRIKES THE HORIZON, THE
GREAT ORANGE COLOSSUS WHO
THREATENS THE VERY EXISTENCE OF
THIS FRAGILE NATION.
WE ARE NOT OVERSTATING IT.
HERE'S A RECENT SAMPLE OF CABLE
NEWS.
KEEP IN MIND AS HE WATCHED,
EVERY ONE OF THESE CLIPS WAS
RECORDED THIS WEEK.
>> ELECTION OFFICIALS ARE
GROWING MORE FEARFUL FOR THEIR
LIVES AS DONALD TRUMP CONTINUES
HIS BIG LIVE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP CONTINUES TO
PUSH LIES ABOUT THE ELECTION,
ELECTORAL RESULTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
>> WHERE WOULD WE BE TODAY IF
THE TRUMP WHITE HAS SIMPLY
LISTENED TO THE SCIENCE?
>> TRUMP WANTS TO OVERTURN THE
NEXT ELECTION, HE WANTS TO
OVERTURN THE LAST ONE, HE WANTS
TO LIMIT VOTING AND OVERTURN
ELECTIONS AT THE STATE LEVEL.
>> MITCH McCONNELL AND KEVIN
McCARTHY DENOUNCE THE
INSURRECTION, DENOUNCED
DONALD TRUMP.
>> TRUMP HAS FOUND A SURPRISING
NEW PLATFORM TO SPREAD THE BIG
LIE.
>> THE THING WITH TRUMP IS TRUMP
IS ALWAYS BAD FOR DEMOCRACY.
>> IT HAS METASTASIZE BEYOND
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I HEAR YOU THERE.
HOWEVER THE ORIGINAL CANCER WAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Tucker: WHAT A FREAK SHOW.
NO WONDER NO ONE WATCHES, WHO
WOULD WATCH THAT QUESTION MIGHT
LISTEN TO WHAT THEY ARE SAYING,
TRUMP WANTS TO OVERTURN THE NEXT
ELECTION, SCREAMS THE PUDGY
MIDGET, THEY ALL DO.
OKAY, GOT IT.
BY DONALD TRUMP IS NO LONGER THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
HE'S GOLFING IN FLORIDA, GOOD
FOR HIM.
HOW ABOUT COVERING WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN AMERICA RIGHT NOW?
A TON OF CHANGE.
MAYBE YOU COULD EXPLAIN IT TO US
OR EVEN TELL US ABOUT IT.
NOW, THEY REFUSE BECAUSE THEY
ARE CAUGHT IN AN EARLIER AGE.
THEY CAN'T ADJUST TO A NEW
REALITY.
DEPRESSING WHEN YOU THINK OF IT,
THAT IS GOING TO BE ALL OF US
SOMEDAY.
IT IS CERTAINLY VERY SAD FOR
THEM.
A FEW YEARS AGO HOSTING A SUNDAY
SHOW ON TELEVISION WAS
CONSIDERED A VERY BIG DEAL IN
WASHINGTON.
NOW, NOBODY CARES.
IT'S IRRELEVANT.
IMAGINE IF YOU WERE THE HOST OF
ONE OF THOSE SHOWS.
CHUCK TODD IS A NEED TO IMAGINE,
HE IS THE HOST OF ONE OF THOSE
SHOWS.
HE SPENT HIS ENTIRE LIFE TRYING
TO GET THIS KID ONLY TO DISCOVER
THAT ONCE HE GOT IT, IT IS NOT
WORTH HAVING.
NO WONDER HE SEEM SO BITTER AND
FRAGILE.
HERE HE IS EARLIER THIS YEAR.
>> THIS WAS STARTED WHEN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA STOP, DROPPED
ANY PRETENSE OF BEING UNBIASED
AND CHOSE SIDES DURING THIS
ELECTION.
THIS FIRE WAS STARTED WHEN YOU
COMPLETELY IGNORED, FOR EXAMPLE,
OUR INVESTIGATION OF HUNTER
BIDEN.
NO EVIDENCE OF WRONGDOING AND WE
FIND OUT, THERE IS A FAIR AMOUNT
OF EVIDENCE WE HAVE A REAL FBI
INVESTIGATION.
>> SENATOR, ALL RIGHT --
>> LISTEN I HAVE HAD ENOUGH OF
THIS TOO --
>> LAST YEAR --
>> A SITUATION WHERE REPUBLICANS
AND CONSERVATIVES DO NOT TRUST
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA AND THAT IS
WHAT HAS DESTROYED THE
CREDIBILITY OF THE MEDIA AND OUR
INSTITUTIONS --
>> THE ELECTION --
>> Tucker: SENATOR, I'VE HAD
ENOUGH BEER CHUCK TODD
CAN'T EVEN BEAR TO LISTEN TO
SOMEONE CRITICIZE THE AMERICAN
NEWS MEDIA.
HE HAS TO NOW APPEAR TO SETTLE
DOWN, CHECK.
NO ONE IS INTERESTED IN WHAT YOU
THINK ANYMORE.
YOUR MOMENT OF AUTHORITY IS LONG
GONE, ALONG WITH IRRELEVANCE.
YOU ARE SHOUTING INTO THE VOID,
YOU ALL ARE.
THEY ALL KNOW THAT.
BUT RATHER THAN ACCEPT THE TRUTH
ABOUT THEM IN THEIR CAREERS OR
REQUIRE BRAND-NEW SCALE, THAT
WOULD BE NICE, OR GRACEFULLY
RETIRE, THIS IS COMING FROM ALL
OF US, THEY WON'T.
THEY HAVE ONE FINAL HOPE FOR
KEEPING THE SCAM ALIVE AND ITS
CENSORSHIP.
THE DYING MEDIA COMPANIES HAVE
CONVINCED THEMSELVES THAT
SOMEHOW THEY CAN GET THE
GOVERNMENT AND THEIR FRIENDS AT
THE TECH MONOPOLIES TO SHUT DOWN
THEIR COMPETITORS AND MAYBE KEEP
IT GOING.
MAYBE THEY WILL BE IMPORTANT,
MAYBE WE CAN RETURN TO 2003 WHEN
PEOPLE DELAYED THE GOLF GAMES TO
WATCH "MEET THE PRESS."
THAT IS THEIR GOAL, DILUTED AS
IT IS.
IT EXPLAINS WHY ALL OF A SUDDEN
JOURNALISTS, OF ALL PEOPLE, ARE
LEADING THE CHARGE AGAINST THE
FIRST AMENDMENT THAT YOU THOUGHT
MADE THEIR JOBS POSSIBLE.
THEY HATE FOX NEWS SO
OBSESSIVELY, AND SUB STACK TOO.
THIS IS THE KEY TO THEIR
CAMPAIGN AGAINST WHAT THEY CALL
MISINFORMATION.
IF YOU ARE A LITERAL MINDED
PERSON, WE CERTAINLY ARE, YOU
LAUGH EVERY TIME YOU HEAR THEM
SAY THAT.
AREN'T THEY THE EXACT SAME
PEOPLE THAT TELL US THAT PUTIN
GOT TRUMP ELECTED?
THAT'S FOR HIGH SCHOOL KID FROM
KENTUCKY WAS IN THE CLAN?
SAME PEOPLE.
OF COURSE THEY ARE NOT AGAINST
MISINFORMATION.
OBVIOUSLY.
THE POINT IS THEY WANT TO
RESTORE THEIR MONOPOLY AND THAT
IS WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO DO.
WE WANT TO BRING YOU AN UPDATE.
AT THE TOP OF THE SHOW TONIGHT,
THE VIRGINIA GOVERNOR'S RACE,
THAT GRACE TOOK A BIZARRE AND
DEEPLY REVEALING TURN TODAY.
SEVERAL PEOPLE CARRYING TORCHES,
NEO-NAZIS SHOWED UP IN FRONT OF
A CAMPAIGN BUS FOR GLENN
YOUNGKIN, THE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE.
THEY CHANTED "WE ARE ALL IN FOR
GLENN."
THE ENTIRE INTERNET EXPLODED, OF
COURSE.
EVERY INFLUENCE OR ON WAS
TELLING YOU, GLENN YOUNGKI